suppose I have a fair coin which I toss
multiple times I want to model a
situation where the results of previous
flips do not affect my beliefs about the
likelihood of heads in the next flip and
I would like to describe the situation
by saying that the coin tosses are
independent you may say we already
defined the notion of independent events
doesn't this notion apply well not quite
we defined independence of two events
but here we want to talk about
independence of a collection of events
for example we would like to say that
the events hands in the first toss heads
in the second toss hands in the third
toss and so on are all independent what
is the right definition let us start
with intuition we will say that a family
of events are independent if knowledge
about some of the events does not change
my beliefs my probability model for the
remaining events for example if I want
to say that events a1 a2 and so on are
independent
I would like relations such as the
following to be true the probability
that event a3 happened and
event a4 does not happen remains the
same even if I condition on some
information about some other events
let's say if I tell you that a 1
happened or that both a to happen and a5
did not happen the important thing to
notice here is that the indices involved
in the event of interest are distinct
from the indices associated with the
events on which I am given some
information
I'm given some information about events
a 1 a 2 and a 5 what happens to them
and this information does not affect my
beliefs about something that has to do
with events a 3 and a 4 I would like all
relations of this kind to be true this
could be one possible definition just
saying that the family of events are
independent if and only if any relation
of this type is true but such a
definition would not be aesthetically
pleasing instead we introduce the
following definition which mimics or
parallels our earlier definition of
independence of two events we will say
that a collection of events are
independent if you can calculate
probabilities of intersections of these
events by multiplying individual
probabilities and this should be
possible for all choices of indices
involved and for any number of events
ever involved let us translate this into
something concrete consider the case of
three events a1 a2 and a3 our definition
requires that we can calculate
probability the probability of the
intersection of two events by
multiplying individual probabilities and
we would like all these three relations
to be true because this property should
be true for any choice of the indices
what do we have here this relation tells
us that a1 and a2 are independent this
relation tells us that a1 and a3 are
independent this relation tells us that
a2 and a3 are independent we call this
situation pairwise independence but the
definition requires something more it
requires that the probability of 3-way
intersections can also be calculated the
same
way by multiplying individual
probabilities and this additional
condition does make a difference as
we're going to see in a later example is
this the right definition yes one can
prove formally that if the conditions in
this definition are satisfied then any
formula of this kind is true in
particular we also have relations such
as the following the probability of
event a 3 is the same as the probability
of event a 3 given that a1 and a2
occurred or the probability of a 3
given that a1 occurred but a2 didn't or
we can continually similarly the
probability of a 3 given that a1 did not
occur and a2 occurred and so on so any
kind of information that I might give
you about events a1 and a2 which one of
them occurred and which one didn't is
not going to affect my beliefs about
event a3 the conditional probabilities
are going to be the same as the
unconditional probabilities I told you
that this definition implies that all
relations of this kind is true this can
be proved the proof is a bit tedious and
we will not go through it